what's up everyone we are here now with
dr. aya Khalil who is not only a
co-producer of the radical wellness
summit but she is also the co-founder of
GN s health care thank you for joining
us thank you thanks for having me all
right so yes tell us a little bit about
this journey the last like eight years
yeah about getting together GN s
healthcare what is it why is it
important yeah so it's really a journey
that started even before eight years in
2000 when we sequenced the human genome
and I was a graduate student at Cornell
physics and my co-founder as well and we
really thought how are we going to you
know take this data now that's going to
be coming from sequencing machines as
well as molecular expression profiling
data from microarrays and turn it into
something that could model and predict
biology very accurately in the same way
that if we think about how we have we
work as physicists we collect data we
model things algorithmically we make
predictions and then we feed that back
into that our mathematics and our
algorithms get more and more accurate
and we doing that we've been able to
predict things like the existence of the
god particle and actually verify it as
well as gravitational waves and so we
wanted to bring that same level of
prediction to biology to medicine
through data through algorithms and
computation and we found that there were
frameworks that we could use to actually
do that around sort of how do you model
causality in a probabilistic way
directly from data okay and so then this
would be something like taking the way
that a cell functions in its everyday
processes and then and then spotting the
beginnings or even before that you're
predicting when it's going to yeah all
of it so it's really saying if I'm
trying to click a it's a combination of
a system
biology approach with machine learning
so I'm trying to understand the cell or
the organism or the dynamics trajectory
of the cell or the human or the organism
and in order for me to learn that and
model that I need to now measure its
components and as you know as rich as I
can possibly get and depending on the
resolution of question so it might be
genomic components it might be molecular
it could be a human EMR clinical
longitudinal record and now once I've
measured it once I've observed it I want
to now reverse engineer reconstruct the
circuitry essentially the circuitry that
tells me how it works you know like you
could pop open your computer and you
could actually see all the different
devices and MOSFETs and whatnot how they
interact essentially we're saying we
want to learn that for a human
whether it's cellular or physiological
or even on the level of how networks and
healthcare work and we can reverse
engineer that learn that from data but
we don't want to just sort of do it in a
way that is looking for a pattern our
correlation because we know that we
often end up you know things don't work
out when we just look at correlations we
really need to understand the cause and
so what we get at is trying to learn
directly what those potential causal
mechanisms are so we're reverse
engineering to understand the circuitry
yeah and to learn it actually learn it
yes and we learn it and then we
represent it computationally so it ends
up being a model an ensemble of circuits
or networks that is the best
representation
the mechanism that gave rise to the data
yeah so for example there is a mechanism
if you have multiple myeloma that you
know predicts and drives why you as a
patient may progress in a more severe
way or you might respond to treatment
and we are going to reverse engineer and
learn that mechanism from data
I like that combo right there mechanism
and data so what is that mechanism what
data is it giving off how do we analyze
that then to predict and understand if
it's going to continue repeating or if
there's going to be disease or what
that's there gonna be there so we
learned that mechanism and then we can
start to play around and ask what if
questions now that I have that that
mathematical circuitry learnt I can put
the patient on drugs off drug and
simulate different scenarios and start
to tease out what would be the best
intervention for that patient and some
of it might be things that treatments
that already exists and we just haven't
given them right off the bat the right
treatment that's best for it and some of
them might be new treatments that we can
now discover because we've learned that
mechanism
okay so then now I'm I'm in I'm in the
process of living and I might have
something going on in my body yeah and
you're now running simulations on the
different ways to apply certain that's
immolations to learn about different
ways to intervene to improve your health
some intervention simulation yeah
exactly so and you can can you get to
apply those intervention simulations as
what-ifs because you've learned the
mechanism and the circuitry directly
from the data
and what this requires lots of data and
different kinds of data so data on
genetic variation data you know from a
blood panel that looks at proteomic
levels data on your longitudinal health
record and we're going to take as much
of it as we can and the data might not
be complete and that's okay because my
models are probabilistic so they're
still going to try to put together a
picture of the the biology of the
mechanism and as accurate of a
probabilistic way as possible and it'll
tell me where I can get at very accurate
predictions but also where I still have
uncertainty and where I'm not quite you
know able to accurately predict but I
can go back and collect more data to
improve that prediction and so our goal
our vision is that for every patient or
person in the healthcare ecosystem that
enough data is collected on them that we
can model out the and project out their
disease or let's you know more
importantly their health trajectory and
if it's starting to change where we
start to predict they're likely to get
diabetes then we can intervene early
enough and we can in silico test out
many interventions and optimize that and
either prevent the disease or if they
already have a disease prevent it
progressing any further
I love how then you can leverage the
data that you're collecting on the body
of how the mechanisms work with then the
data that you're collecting from the
simulations of how different remedies
are going to affect yeah that's that's a
crucial combination that's a crucial
combination and it's it's a you know
you're learning causality so that when
you learn causality you can do these
intervention simulations yeah exactly
that's it yeah causality and
intervention simulations yeah and then
the math is what it gives us the Cystic
rigorous way to learn the causality yes
I comes from folks like a Judea pearl
who wanted
during a word for this work on-call
inference and reasoning combined with
optimization and sampling and search
method that physicists and engineers
love to use to scale up these problems
and do the searches and then Monte Carlo
simulation to do those intervention
simulations just have 80 people now we
have 80 people were growing and so by
the time someone sees this will be even
bigger yeah but and it's what I'm really
proud of is just that the
multidisciplinary team that we have like
we have theoretical physicists solving
integrals you know I've actually had to
weigh in on an Ergo left wait a minute
we're simply good at this way side by
side with an epidemiologist with a
permutation and they're all coming
together to come up with hardened math
to solve these problems compute to scale
these four big problems and then make
sense of it in a clinical and
biologically meaningful way that's so
amazing so it's you and then who is the
other minor is Colin Howe
Colin hill yes and we have a chief
mathematics officer and the company has
been with us early on and on the early
founding team Bruce Church and many many
other amazing people - too many to name
and they're super smart I like that
multidisciplinary approach very similar
to what we do with the show very multi
and so what is the we kind of touched on
the vision yeah but just give us a real
concrete like give an example today
being applied yeah absolutely
so today that the main use cases because
the technology it's very powerful in a
way it's a it's a tool box that allows
you to solve many problems but what
coming up consistently where we can make
an impact today so somewhere around you
know how do we and we are doing this
with health plans where we can model out
the disease trajectory of patients our
members we don't call them patients and
we're dealing with health plans and
identify ways to intervene and I get
from a care management perspective
what's the optimal set of care
management interventions that you can
apply to prevent disease progression or
even prevent disease altogether and
health plans and providers are actually
looking to exploit their data to get
those answers and you provide that
insight to the care giver so they can go
you're better off having a really strong
adherence program with a constant
nurse's visit and that's going to have
the biggest impact on your health
another is for pharmaceutical companies
and here we are in in Cambridge in
Boston
surrounded by you know probably enough
biotech companies to fill many cities
not just one and lots of innovative
treatments and by the time they get to
testing them in man and patient we're
still figuring out the biological
patient human response so we take data
from clinical trials where each person
the clinical trial will have had a
sample or a biopsy taken we have their
full clinical records from the trial and
we combine it with molecular data so
that we can learn okay these are the
patients who are really benefiting from
the rack and these those are ones who
are not benefiting so that when you go
to a Phase three or go to the market you
know who to target your drugs towards
and we really want to see these tools
and capabilities to really help us match
interventions with our drug or a non
drug to that to that individual so that
when you apply treatment you know not
thirty percent of the time that it's
going to work but ninety-nine
it's going to work yeah I like the non
drug side of things as well that seems
to be very complicated and I often to
apply therapy that's human there yeah no
I mean all of these ways to you know as
we know health isn't just about drug
treatments it's all about the things
that you do outside of that yeah
behavior modification and and whatnot
but a lot of folks are very committed to
helping patients and here more figuring
out what the right Co beta gives
somebody because it's actually an
incentive whether or not they end up
going to see their doctor so there's
lots of leverage that we can play with
that combined when drug treatments can
be used to optimize health yo yes this
and that's what all this is about as
well it's optimization of help yeah so
we see you guys
co-produced this event now this is yeah
how many people are here oh I don't know
I think we're close to like 130 people
now 130 people yeah awesome yeah man
wanting to learn about radical oh that's
right it's not just being healthy about
radically yeah exactly
keeping the 15 year olds health yeah
throughout your lifetime yeah yeah until
you want it yeah yeah and we wanted to
bring just different thought leaders in
the space together to talk about this
because it is gonna be a convergence and
I really believe in that
multidisciplinary and convergence of
ideas to make progress and it's also I
think about stating a commitment one of
the things I talked about on my panel
today is if I could get every biologist
and clinician to start to think
mathematically quantitatively if I can
give them all to think in that way and
start to implement that and their
paradigms as what they do normally is
amazing clinicians and biologists well
it'll change everything yeah
there's this there's this way of
thinking of being values first or
mission-driven or not prioritizing
consumption that can speak as
consumption but prioritizing impact yeah
and that has been a major pillar of our
project as well as the way that we try
and communicate and inspire other people
under think yeah and I totally feel that
from the vibe the vibe here is radical
wellness for all how did he get this
driving the prices down getting a more
applicable to people's lives the
conversations like this yeah okay any
last thoughts that you think are
important sure I just got back from the
Milken Conference and at you know and
that's discussing all kinds of issues on
a global scale and I had to speak on a
panel around machine learning AI
medicine hope or hype and I think for me
it you know what with all of the issues
around our health and policy and you
know how do you democratize technology
it's still very hopeful and and the hope
is there you know not just for like hey
are we going to cure cancer but for all
of us as we age and disease and now is
the time to actually mobilize and figure
out not just how to solve the hard
problems the technology the hard math
but the things that are softer but also
just as hard policy and reimbursement
and access
yeah and on top of everything that you
just mentioned there about all these
different systems coming together yeah I
love how you take this physics approach
to the mechanism yeah so interesting
because that's typically not what people
think about when it comes to biology is
how is it physically working right in
its mechanical level yeah and then how
can we take that data analyze it and try
and make predictive analytics on that
yeah and don't even get us started on
policy looks and I don't get a started
on globalization Aaron Collins who's
who's sequencing for the cheapest across
the world
what about bio warfare in genetic
engineering there's so many things that
go into those yeah so anything's figure
out and we need we're gonna do more of
these right we're in a more of these so
we'll put links in the bio thank you
everyone for tuning in and I had a good
time good yeah awesome all right